sat down with one of my kids just about
a year ago
and here was the conversation I had I
have a very special brain
and my brain pays very close attention
to certain things and it is very good at
reading a room
and because it's good at reading a room
I can I I can make people feel
comfortable
and give them some peace I can also make
people feel very uncomfortable because
then I'm not when I'm not paying
attention right
and I told one of my kids you have that
same special brain
and
it's a gift and it's just something that
makes us different and we have to work
through some things that other people
have to work through
and that phrase special brain
and the phrase I have it too
and the phrase
and so we have some extra work to do
those are your three magic points